[Music]
who keeps you up at night
for me it's many things but I probably
share the same worries as you do about
the future the uncertainty of the path
before me but I'll never forget what he
told me
[Music]
that there's always a story behind
everything behind some his actions
if someone's words were intended to hurt
it's how we understand if they are
hurting inside and there's a story
behind the world how many are fighting
and fought and shed blood over the
history of power inequality war
corruption but we must understand it to
me forward
you
this is him pray band Potawatomi but
ascendant of chief Abram Burnett and
whiskey Dominic our family is documented
by the US Smithsonian Institute in
Library of Congress and the tribe there
are less than 10 speakers left he is an
educator and performer of authentic
traditional Native song and dance but
above all else he's my dad
[Music]
I'm 18 this is me
and worry like any other person but I
feel a bit scared because what happens
when a story is forgotten agree honey
Mira commit ninda Plympton mean box
mean Get Set is pikia can't make it a
what a paparazzi angle now condemned we
are joke TT Ashok Nagar Jaya even gay
Mahesh know what what myths oh they were
met so queer a kick kick
the same dog Maria Maria Navarre kisses
kisses they walk members for day not
million name Edie not more deer wagon
Yahweh need Walton give me oh nice Navi
money
bourree pas de nada
oh hi
[Music]
oh gosh equation
Oh
we're Anishinabe mich Navi Potawatomi
Chippewa I'm enrolled with the prairie
band Potawatomi Sameach to Kansas
originally we're a Great Lakes tribe we
occupied about 28 million acres
historically eventually through
complicated warfare sensitive history
our people will be located during the
Removal Act to Missouri Iowa and into
Kansas during that time our people had
to learn to change our great-grandfather
cheap whiskey a Mook is the biological
grandson of chief semoga one known
better as chief sonali who was the
principal chief of the prairie band this
here is a photograph of him taking in
1921 by an anthropologist named Jesse
Nussbaum who actually took this
photograph for one silver dollar my
great-grandfather's brother
his name is Walker - crew this is a
photograph of my grandfather in 1906
along with his father
whiskey Adamiak was sitting at center
this is documented in the Library of
Congress in Washington DC and this is my
grandfather's mother
Roseanne lastly k ol corn iguana here is
a photograph of my grandfather here in
1963 your great-grandfather that's him
there in Kansas documented as a ritual
leader and elder
at the time taken by James Clifton now
on our family and our citizen van nation
this is chief not wish ma no better as
chief Abram Burnett in his right hand
he's holding a cane this is the actual
cane here that still also remains with
us in the family and of course it's not
American Indian It's Made in Paris
France
your grandfather my father here taking
around 1967 with some other tribal
members George Allen Bernard qisas Gary
whiskey Kadam you Kurdish pacano and
James Cagney got taken by James Howard
anthropologists around 1950 that's your
family I remember learning at a dance
when I was really little four or five
years old and I loved it
just because it was so fun and that was
before I learned that many languages are
fading away before I started questioning
the history in textbooks and before
learning about the complicated world of
politics maybe we made a mistake maybe
we should not have humored him in that
wanting to stay in that kind of
primitive lifestyle maybe we should have
said no come join us these citizens
there's a weight that lingers now and I
think it's the fear of losing a part of
our identity forever but everyone
worries and wonders about how we'll be
remembered after we pass away and maybe
it's that fear of being forgotten
makes us want to tell more stories
because if you don't tell your story who
will or will someone else write it
instead or will it just be lost in time
forever I don't know but I still try to
keep that spirit when I was a kid just
not to worry so much out of love and I
miss that a lot of things for myself
growing up almost like a wanderer like
many of my friends from other enrolled
tribal nations a lot of us trying to
find ourselves in the world again we
asked what does it really mean to be a
native person we are people that are
from a tribal society a nation but are
we really a tribe we are descendants of
something that once was I always tell
people that I'd be lying to you always
if I tried to pretend that I was really
living a lifestyle fully like my
relatives and descendants did long ago
today as an American Indian we struggle
with keeping language alive keeping true
culture and customs alive there are so
many influences in the world and
materialistic things around are people
that have basically destroyed the world
of native societies most people believe
that all natives are receiving some form
of money from the federal government
because their natives that had to deal
with complicated and sensitive history
but the truth is is that our people do
not receive money from the federal
government
manner that most Americans think they
believe we don't pay taxes which is not
true they believe that all natives go to
school and colleges anywhere and anytime
they want for free that's not true and
that all Native Americans have some form
of casino upon their Indian Reservation
which is extremely not true most tribes
live in a reality of poverty most tribes
live in a reality of high rate of
suicide alcoholism depression these are
all things that have broken down over
the generations to strategically destroy
the tribe and the nation the reservation
was a concentration camp it was a place
to imprison the Native Society away from
their ways of thinking from their way of
living from the way that they centered
themselves in their own world so how do
you become native what does it mean does
it mean having long hair does it mean
how many feathers I can put in my head
today most society and Americans believe
that that's what it means to be native
now but that's really not the truth the
truth goes back to you as a human being
and how our people long ago looked at
the world and how they centered
themselves being native was being one
with earth being one with water being
one with the spirit world being one with
the world of consciousness being one
with the world of someone who was alive
and awake when one's body is sick and
damaged
and one when one passes on to the spirit
world
our people look at the realm of sky and
space the universe the realm of water
the realm of land the realm of the dream
world these are places that our people
looked upon we are descendants of
something that once was but there are
many trying to hold on to those old ways
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
whoa
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Oh